so guys a lot of times I hear about the
gender pay Gap and I was actually having
a conversation with someone this weekend
and it was a feminist of course talking
about oh I'm so oppressed my life is so
hard there's all these reasons women are
not paid as much and I'll say this women
are not paid as much because they're
lazy they don't want to do the hard jobs
and they love to and moan even
though they do less work women want a
work life balance which is totally fine
but what comes with a work life life
balance is less pay women love to take
vacations women love to spend money they
don't have and then cry about it later
women are terrible at negotiating and
women tend to have easier jobs